Martin Score says he has just released
one of his greatest movies and it seems
like nobody cares so why didn't
audiences turn out for killers of the
flower Moon 2023 continues to be a
strange confusing year for box office
expectations shorefire summer fixtures
like The Flash and Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny wound up as box office
failures losing their respective Studios
millions of dollars meanwhile an
unexpected number of mature adult
oriented pictures have triumphed at the
box office including the controversial
sound of freedom and Christopher Nolan's
3-hour biopic Oppenheimer the success of
these diverse practically iess films was
promising signaling that upcoming
adult-oriented projects could post
record-breaking box office figures
unfortunately director Martin scor's
highly anticipated killers of the flower
Moon which also fits into that category
flopped on a reported budget of $2
million Cori's latest picture debuted at
$23 million worldwide the Leonardo
Caprio and Robert dairo Leed film to
date has red in just under $90 million
globally a far cry from its N9 figure
budget killers of the flower moon will
likely end its box office run around or
just above a $100 million worldwide
which would place a 3-hour plus epic as
one of the director's highest grossing
films while Martin Score says he is by
no means an automatic box office draw he
stands out as one of the most widely
beloved contemporary filmmakers it says
a lot that Score says he was actually
able to convince Apple Studios to Grant
him a $200 million budget for an outr
dialog heavy crime film with a massive
runtime when you consider the fact that
the film might fail to even break the
$110 million barrier that bloated budget
feels like a major source of blame and
seeing as a picture had a 60% drop
domestically during its second weekend
it's safe to say that there's no
scenario where Killers makes its $200
million budget back when films like
Christopher Nolan's Oppenheimer are
being made for as little as $100 million
you can't help but wonder what scorsi
did with that $200 million well for one
thing variety claims that apple and
scorsi granted lead star Leonardo
DiCaprio a $30 million salary that's a
bumbling and Despicable Ernest burkart
in a world where Adam Driver can readily
agree to receive a pay cut to ensure
films like Ferrari get made it's
mind-boggling that Apple afforded
DiCaprio such a massive salary perhaps a
more modest budget would have helped
Killers post at least a minimal
theatrical profit one thing worth
mentioning killers of the flower moon is
a cinematic Triumph with a Rotten
Tomatoes rating of 93% and an
overwhelmingly positive a minor Cinema
score score says his latest is nothing
short of a career highlight for the
director and to Stella cast and for some
like Lupa critic Audrey Fox the film's
206 minute runtime only gave it more
room to meditate on the tragedy of the
oage people unfortunately the 3-hour
plus runtime seem to be pushing it for
General audience members take to social
media sites like Reddit and you'll find
several users arguing that it's best to
skip the film's theatrical release
because it's just too damn long one
reitor writes I'll wait to watch it in
nice 4K Dolby Vision at home where I can
pause Etc You could argue that
Oppenheimer which was just 25 minutes
shorter than Killers was able to prosper
at the box office but SC sayi latest
simply doesn't have the same cultural
momentum as Nolan's epic put short
Barbie helped hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie can
killers of the flower moon is a star
studded Affair featuring Leonardo
DiCaprio Robert dairo Jesse plens
Brandon Fraser John litho and more
that's a whole lot of Oscar winners and
nominees in one film the movie also
features a career defining performance
from Lily Gladstone whose character
Molly fools for DiCaprio's greedy
Earnest as compelling as the film's
premise might be killers of the flower
moon is marketable primarily because of
its cast unfortunately the movies actors
weren't able to promote the picture
because of the SAG after strike in which
actors are demanding the rates they
deserve the strike which kicked off in
July 2023 forbids actors from promoting
or marketing any of their projects
because of this the cast wasn't allowed
to promote the film in interviews during
press junkets or on late night talk
shows while Martin Score says he
certainly tried his best to promote the
film The Director doesn't have the same
recognizability or clout as the Caprio
or dairo beyond that no promotion meant
no opportunity for the film's indigenous
actors to discuss the film's import
conerns regarding the tragedy of the
oage nation perhaps the performance of
Oppenheimer left box office pundits with
far too much optimism while the runaway
success of Christopher Nolan's
astonishing Masterpiece is certainly
mindboggling it should be remembered
that Nolan is a Brandon to himself the
creative Maverick boasts a number of box
office hits several of which were
original projects but even without the
expectations set by Oppenheimer it's
hard to imagine Killers succeeding in
any scenario without a lower budget in
recent years historical epics have
haven't enjoyed much momentum at the box
office 2022 is Babylon a $110 million
film set in the 1920s only made $63
million Ridley Scott's 2021 movie The
Last dual which featured Adam Driver jod
comr and Matt Damon in lead roles failed
to make more than $30 million at the box
office even scori 17th century set
magnum opus silence could have make its
reported $45 million budget back in 2016
so what chance did killer stand
considering it Costo it really does seem
like Oppenheimer was the exception and
not the rule when it comes to historical
epics succeeding in the current
theatrical landscape now I am become
death the destroyer of worlds ultimately
killers of the flower moon were more
than likely failed to make a profit at
the global box office but that doesn't
really matter because intention is
extremely important when it comes to
digesting this film's numbers for Apple
TV plus killers of the flower Moon
posting a profit isn't as important as a
film dominating award season there's
there a reason why Netflix and apple
have been giving scorsi hundreds of
millions of dollars to do whatever the
heck he wants it's because he provides
results while his projects don't make as
much as the MCU films he's repeatedly
criticized Score says his films attract
Prestige and awards something streamers
VI for as the distribution industry
drastically changes for Apple TV plus
and distributor Paramount Pictures every
dollar killers of the flower Moon makes
is gravy on top of all that Prestige and
name recognition and don't forget
killers of the flower moon is first and
fourth most Builders an apple original
meaning it will only be available on
Apple TV plus once it dashes out of
Cinemas this is a streaming play really
one that just so happens to have a
traditional theatrical release and what
the film has made so far shouldn't be
understated either Killers made $440
million during its opening weekend and
is on track to make over $100 million
globally this is nothing short of a
miracle in a world where Netflix
abandons the Irish man theatrically and
where that film failed to make even $1
million due to a limited release it's
fantastic that apple is affording
scorsetti a full 3,000 theater plus wide
release